[Music]
straight ahead
online crime daily taylor swift takes to
twitter claiming her albums
were sold from underneath her but does
she have a legal argument
plus a former cheerleader is back in
court after burying her baby in her
backyard
should skyler richardson be taken off
probation early i suffer a lot in
silence and i
i do show remorse and i am very sorry
and a former football player gets
cleared of all charges
find out how an attorney lands himself
in jail
long crime daily covers court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
pop star taylor swift is speaking out
about the sale of her master recordings
by her former manager the singer had
been fighting for ownership of her first
six albums from her former music label
scooter braun reportedly sold the albums
to a private equity firm
for 300 million dollars swift took to
twitter saying she's never been given a
chance
to buy her masters back i would have to
sign a document that would silence me
forever
before i could even have a chance to bid
on my own work
my legal team said that this is
absolutely not normal
and they've never seen an nda like this
presented
unless it was to silence an assault
accuser by paying them off
criminal defense attorney adam conte is
here to provide analysis
along with terry austin terry this nda
seemed like there was a lot of bad
blood did it stop swift's team from
meaningfully negotiating
for her are these even typical
yeah you know what i do think it stopped
them from negotiating and no
it's not typical usually you use an nda
when you want to
negotiate a settlement agreement and you
want to keep those terms and conditions
confidential but here they're just
trying to negotiate
buying back her rights and i think to
say that you can't say anything
negative about the other party is a
little bit of an overreach
you do have non-disparagement agreements
but that's usually in the employment
context and
that's not this case adam it seemed that
taylor swift can still re-record songs
from these albums
should she just shake it off and start
recording these new songs and make some
money
i think she should shake it off uh
here's the problem that i have with this
she's the one being mean i believe on
this situation
it's not normal to have an nda in
something like this but normal people
don't have millions of millions of
twitter followers
and social media followers willing to
attack scooter braun
bought rights to her songs legally he
didn't do it behind anybody's back he
did it legally
he owns them she doesn't like that i get
that that's tough
but when she had a problem with
performing at the grammys she took to
twitter
went after him and he received death
threats so i think it's
totally okay in this particular
situation
that he would want some sort of
protection from her throngs of maniacal
fans
looking to tear him to pieces all right
an ohio woman acquitted of murdering her
newborn baby
but found guilty for improperly burying
her infant
in her parents backyard goes back to
court
skylar richardson pleaded that her
probation end early
law and crimes angenette levy shows us
what happened in court
skyler richardson has made the long walk
down this hallway with her father scott
many times but this is the last time she
hopes to do it
as she asks the judge in her case to
terminate her probation
22 months early i want to be able to
contribute to society
as much as i can and be able to
prove that you made the right decision
and giving me the opportunity to re go
back out into the society
so again i apologize to everyone that
i've affected
one of those people is tracy johnson her
son was the father of skylar
richardson's baby girl
annabelle first i want to tell you
i don't hate you i know you probably
think i do
i don't i want you to know that from me
richardson was found guilty of gross
abuse of a corpse for burying annabelle
and her parents backyard
shortly after giving birth in their home
richardson claimed the baby was
stillborn
johnson says richardson has shown no
remorse
so if that's the first bad thing you do
and you do it at 18 years old
and show absolutely no remorse for it
where do you go from there she's living
her best life
she's not reach out to the people whose
life she's destroyed
richardson's probation officer said
she's followed all the rules paid all
fines as attending college and works
part time for her lawyer
the now 21 year old says she suffers in
silence
and does show remorse for her daughter i
just want to
show that i can be a normal person again
that's all
so i am i i apologize for not showing
more
um and i just want to make everything
right again
as much as i can so i do apologize after
the hearing schuyler richardson and her
attorney declined to comment
but in the hearing richardson said that
she wants to finish college
and then attend law school in lebanon
ohio i'm angenette levy for law and
crime daily
judge donald oda presided over
richardson's trial
and granted her request to end her
three-year probation
just after 14 months
the perception of this case is
[Music]
you know that you know mrs richardson
that a lot of people don't agree with
the verdict
think he got away with murder or
whatever
that's the perception of this case and
that's sort of what carries
uh some of this the reality of this case
though is that this is a low-level
felony
you have no prior criminal history you
are employed
you are going to college and there is no
reason for me to invest
the time and resources of my probation
department
and supervising you probation is not
punishment probation is not
rehabilitation
probation is giving you an opportunity
to demonstrate
why it is that the stated prison term of
12 months in prison should not be
imposed judge oda said richardson's
action made him believe
she would not commit other crimes terry
straight question was this the right
decision
you know i know many people are going to
disagree with me but i think it was
the right decision listen was she
responsible in some
shape or form for the death of her baby
yes
but will she commit other crimes i don't
think so
she really has shown that she is
rehabilitated the fact she's going to
school she's trying to work
i don't think that she should remain on
probation i do think we should give her
an
opportunity to lead the rest of her life
because she's shown that she can do
just that now adam criminal defense
attorney to criminal defense attorney
have you ever heard a judge describe
probation that way
it's bizarre how do we get that for our
clients
i i have no idea i want to know how i go
into court
with a client uh who is from a
worse socioeconomic background who got
caught selling a bag of heroin
to support his family maybe and go into
a judge
any judge in new york city and see what
they say
i am befuddled i think befuddled is the
right word
uh for this situation it's not like she
had like a seven-year jail sentence and
she was asking to be released
a little bit early she was on probation
something that requires her probably
to check in once a month for three years
not 10 years three years there's a
a dead baby at the heart of this case
and i understand that she was acquitted
of that
but in no world can i picture a judge
saying that to one of our clients in new
york city
uh or or or having this demeanor towards
it
i get that you know you can argue that
this is a waste of resources and she
might not commit a crime again
but the state was not asking a lot of
her to be on probation for
for 36 months i am very surprised by
this
yeah good decision just i've never seen
that before
still ahead on law and crime daily the
family of a woman killed by a texas
police officer
is demanding justice and later a
defendant's words are being used against
her
erica stefanko ruthless killer or just a
wife venting
[Music]
we're following the murder trial of
erica stefanco where new evidence is
adding a new twist
to this love triangle stefanko is
accused of helping her husband
kill his ex over a cussy dispute
prosecutors say stefonko placed a fake
pizza order at domino's to
lure ashley bigs to her death biggs
worked as a delivery
driver and was later found dead in her
car in a cornfield
christopher cobb pled guilty to
murdering biggs and helped to implicate
stefanco in court the jury heard the
recordings by
cobb's mother made by the defendant
allegedly confessing to her involvement
[Applause]
[Applause]
and it wasn't because it was forcing me
to do it or like he had a gun in my head
it was because he said this is your part
and this is what you're gonna do
which is how it always was what we're
supposed to do
this recording sat in a save for four
years before sidney cobb
handed over as evidence after stefanko
divorced her son
at trial she asked not to have her face
shown
but you felt that somehow erica was
responsible
yes did you believe eric was completely
responsible for him being there or
partially responsible
partially it took two what prompted you
to record erica
off and on through the years we would
have
issues if she got upset about something
she would withhold the kids from us it
would be you know
until we can sit down and talk the kids
aren't going to be able to come over
this happened several times we had just
come back from vacation
and she wanted to meet with us with me
to talk and it was during this time
where
chad was wanting the divorce told the
tools
situation i decided i was just going to
record
tired of always being called on the mat
and always having the kids withheld from
us
seems like a little bit of animus there
adam a four-year-old recording
that the mother-in-law breaks out after
her son's divorce to the defendant
how does a defense attorney attack that
at cross
well you know the four-year-old
defendants a little bit or the
four-year-old recordings a little bit of
a red herring right yeah yeah it's an
old recording
but it's still her words and she's not
denying him that it's hers
i think it's the single most damning
piece of evidence in this trial
um what they can do is in which that
clip didn't show
is that cindy cobb the mom she did admit
that she gave
uh she gave erica alcohol that day that
they were drinking
you can even hear erica asking for quote
the hard stuff so i think what they're
going to need to do is sort of try to
apply an argument of
um yeah she said that but it was sort of
in the context she was
she was she'd been drinking a lot she
felt really guilty that anything had
happened to ashley
and just being with chad involved in any
way
even though she didn't know she that he
was she was going to get murdered
she just felt bad for her and saying she
played her part that's where i'm
guessing they're going to go with it but
it's a really tough piece of evidence to
overcome
yeah it's really damning evidence the
defense argued terry that the recording
was taken out of context as adam said
but it's still in is this the
prosecutor's case to win now
well i i agree with you i think the
prosecution is going to use that
recording to their advantage and
couple it with what chad had to say one
thing i will say about
cindy or cynthia cobb the mother is she
is
definitely a huge supporter of her son
she actually didn't like ashley that
much based on her testimony
she didn't like brittany ashley's
girlfriend and frankly she didn't like
erica i think she would say and do
anything she possibly could to support
her son definitely supporting her son to
the end we'll see how that plays out
when we come back a gold-plated carry-on
canceled rapper little wayne's private
flight
now he's facing federal charges plus no
flag on the play for a former nfl player
in a criminal case against him
but that's just where the case gets
interesting more when we return
the family of a woman killed by a police
officer in her own home
is suing the city of fort worth texas
terry austin has the details
brian tatiana jefferson was shot
standing in her window by officer aaron
dean last year
her family filed a wrongful death
lawsuit against the city
they're arguing dean failed to identify
himself before drawing his weapon
dean was responding to a wellness check
of her home
the incident was captured on his body
camera he fired within
seconds of seeing her and is now facing
a murder charge
rapper lil wayne was been charged with
a federal gun offense in miami
authorities say the
gold-plated gun was found in the
rapper's luggage
when he arrived in miami on a private
plane
he's accused of possessing a firearm by
a convicted felon a charge
that carries a potential sentence of up
to 10 years in prison
thank you terry all robbery charges have
been
dropped against a former new york giants
player but the victim's attorney is now
behind bars
prosecutors in broward county florida
dropped robbery charges against
ex-cornerback
de'andre baker baker had been accused of
holding up four men at gunpoint
at a fort lauderdale barbecue the
attorney for the alleged victims is
accused of telling baker's attorney
his clients would stop cooperating with
investigators and change their stories
in exchange for more than 260 thousand
dollars
each baker was released from the giants
after the arrest
terry the defense attorney is getting to
the
defensive party getting to the truth
happens all the time but extortion
charges against a defense attorney
what is he in for you know he's in for a
lot here brian i mean
the least he could get is a warning from
the ethics committee
but he could also lose his license to
practice
and even worse you know they could bring
charges against him for
extortion all they'd have to show is
that you know there was something that
he obtained of value
in exchange for these threats and i
think that exists here
i don't know adam i'm thinking bye-bye
law license for this attorney
do you think this is a potential trial
or is this going to be a hard plea the
attorney
must take considering the evidence
against him
well it depends um what the articles
don't say is what exactly
uh you know he was he was saying
so if he was saying you can almost craft
it in a way
to say my clients are not interested in
cooperating
they are interested in having being
compensated this will have
no impact on how they decide what to say
or not to say
but i mean what i'm what i'm
hypothesizing is so
improbable as to what actually happened
and
uh yeah i think his law license is gone
i think he's gonna get arrested
i think it'll probably be a a trial
because attorneys are
are pretty hard up for taking pleas but
but i want to know too
that this doesn't mean that uh de andre
baker didn't do
this crime uh but because of this now
the charges are dismissed because the
witnesses have no credibility
so it could be the greatest thing that
ever happened to deandre baker also
adam i saw a quick change of hey maybe
the attorney is not guilty to i don't
know two attorneys talking to themselves
it's probably gonna be a guilty plea uh
i'd say it's gonna be a tough case
anyways but thanks for that adam when we
come back coven 19 concerns
dominate a court hearing for the accused
parkland school shooter
when will nicholas cruz case go to trial
copen 19 concerns have stalled the
highly anticipated trial of the accused
parkland high school shooter
nicholas cruz in a heated hearing cruz
is charged with murdering
17 people at marjory stoneman douglas
high school
back in 2018 but his team of public
defenders wants him to be evaluated
for mental competency as they work on
his defense
the judge arranged for special
permission with the jail so that experts
could speak with him
in person but one of the attorneys says
they still don't feel comfortable
with this arrangement
i told you i am in constant
communication with the sheriff's office
about
this matter i have also told you that i
have
and i am aware that we have health
compromised individuals on this team
without going into specifics or
revealing strategy on this particular
case
i am not in a position to tell the court
which member is capable or able to go
into that jail
i am however as officer of the court
informing the court
that with good faith this team is not
going to be exposed or expose anyone in
that jail due to
the fact that this court or the jail
wants to have experts in the jail
the defense asks for all parties to be
rapidly tested but the jail says
they don't have the capability to do
that
they're already mixing the whole plan
because they're requiring something that
we don't have to provide we don't have
to rapid test our employees
well we're making a whole bunch of
exceptions for mr cruz's case so perhaps
we can make that exception no no we're
making exceptions for
all cases regarding this we've actually
had private attorneys reach out
also wanting their experts to come into
our facility all the all the services
are disinfected
everybody wears masks if you want them
to work a95 masks that is
acceptable as well i mean those are
standard protocol
but um you're basically telling us if we
don't rapidly test our employees you're
not doing this
the judge grew increasingly frustrated
by the fact the lawyers had not reached
a decision
what i'm hearing is a bunch of
generalizations and all i'm asking
is that everyone please make their best
efforts to see if we can do this if we
can't and you can't you can't but if you
can
there's no reason to litigate this right
now without knowing
i'm just asking that we try and that we
specifically bring
uh specific objections or specific
issues to my attention
on this case adam you're a practicing
criminal defense attorney during the
coveted times is everyone facing these
frustrations
yeah everyone's facing these
frustrations figure out a compromise
find maybe a small group of employees
get them rapidly tested but
this guy's not going out of jail anytime
soon there's no rush just do whatever is
the safest
terry mental comp mental competency
evaluations sorry require extensive
testing
and an examination is it even possible
considering incarceration joining
during covid it is possible brian
because with the proper precautions like
shields masks distance
you know you can definitely be evaluated
in prison and look we're going to have
to get used to
operating like this post cove at 19. all
right we're going to have to figure this
out
because as the prosecutor is saying
we've got to move
forward on this case adam with all these
precautions needing to happen
do you see a trial happening anytime
soon
i don't see any trial happening anytime
soon no
all right so we're going to continue to
watch this case i know adam we both
practice in new york
some of the courts in new york have said
no grand juries or no trials
indefinitely for the rest of the year so
i'm thinking that the case of nicholas
cruz out of florida
may be somewhat similar adam conte terry
austin thank you as always for joining
us
thank you for joining us here at the law
on crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you